now all right let's go to our caller
from the five one nine area code who's
calling today from five one nine
hi David this is Jesse hey Jesse what's
going on not too much I'm a huge fan of
your show and I really appreciate you
having me on thank you um I just have
two questions for you the one is do you
think the left is giving their power
away by not giving enough empathy to
people on the right maybe even Donald
Trump you know kind of dehumanizing him
and being sort of vicious and losing
sites of you know the fact that he's
just a person and be I don't know take
it one at a time how is the left
dehumanizing Trump I see a lot more
dehumanization coming from Trump than to
Trump
oh absolutely so what I'm saying like
I'm a progressive and that's one of the
reasons why I've watched your show
because you're very balanced in your
judgments but you also are kind of a
lefty like myself it seems like so what
I'm saying is even though we have people
who do terrible things at the end of the
day when we stop treating them like
people and start treating them like
monsters it almost gives them more power
in a sense would you agree with that I
think that there are circumstances in
which that's true yeah yeah and it kind
of leads into my second question is do
you think the left and some of the
public speakers on the left like even
though or talk-show hosts and
what-have-you
like Stephen Colbert evangelized Trump's
brand more than they take him down in a
sense you mean inadvertently yeah
so I noticed that ever since Donald
Trump started running for presidency
Stephen Colbert can't help but disgust
Trump and this seems like a widespread
thing on the left yeah and my concern I
live in Canada by the way so I'm just
kind of watching everything unfold my
concern is that by always focusing on
him making him a monster not kind of
bringing
down to a human level and if they don't
stop talking about them they're actually
evangelizing I don't know you can make
the case that if you just if media
literally pays no attention to someone
that person becomes no one because they
go away Trump is the President of the
United States he would still be doing
things even if people didn't pay
attention and people wouldn't be aware
of the things that he is doing which are
objectively bad so I understand the
point you're trying to make I think it's
more about finding a balance but no I
have no particular reason to think that
someone like Stephen Colbert is actually
evangelizing for trumpism okay well
thank you so much for your time today I
really appreciate it all right Jesse
appreciate the phone call thank you so
much